this economy has got to work for
everyone and right now we know that it
is and it's gonna take all of us coming
together to make sure that it does
necesito mas in Cuvier cada persona en
el éxito
de este upon omean pero si quiere Moses
arizo necesitamos in qui cada persona in
Westra democracia cada votar caca de
votante necesitamos la representación y
cada vez
necesitamos escuchar right now we have a
system that favors those who can pay for
access and outcomes that's how you
explain an economy that is rigged to
corporations and the very wealthiest a 2
trillion dollar tax cut that favored
corporations while they were sitting on
record piles of cash and the very
wealthiest in this country at a time of
historic wealth inequality a new
democracy that is revived because we
return power to the people
no pacts no gerrymandering automatic and
same-day voter registration to bring in
more voters and a new Voting Rights Act
to get rid of the barriers in the place
now that's how we each have a voice in
our democracy and make this economy work
for everybody that's my answer I'll give
you 10 seconds to answer if you want to
answer the direct question would you
support a 70% individual marginal tax
rate yes/no or pass I would support a
tax rate and a tax code that is fair to
everyone tax capital at the same rate
that you you tax ordinary income take
that corporate tax rate up to 28% you
would generate the revenues you need to
pay for the programs we're talking
that's time thank you